ataques rusos en todos los frentes las
fuerzas del kremlin intensificaron su
ofensiva militar desde el sur hasta el
norte del país la artillería golpeó
tanto objetivos militares como civiles
desde mykolaiv hasta jarquín y también
en las inmediaciones de la capital kiev
donde brad a una columna de humo
hubo una explosión me tiraron luego hubo
niebla todo cubierto de polvo de
hormigón en este caos saltamos al
apartamento vecino para refugiarnos allí
no había puertas nada nos quedamos en el
pasillo entre dos paredes eso nos salvó
un gusto
el resultado varios muertos y decenas de
heridos en todo el territorio ucraniano
en la región oriental de doñetsk los
bombardeos rusos se han vuelto paisaje
para muchos habitantes mientras las
tropas del kremlin avanzan para hacerse
con el control total del área
separatista del donbass y acuitzio tocó
touch yo sólo oí un impacto un impacto y
ya sabe nuestra casa porque vivimos un
poco más lejos sólo se arrancó la
esquina del tejado el mandatario
volodymyr telesquí describió el inicio
de la jornada como una mañana turbulenta
después de que las sirenas antiaéreas
comenzarán a sonar en medio de una
sesión parlamentaria
el presidente lituano ahora si es que te
vestiste y visca las tropas terroristas
rusas acompañan la festividad de hoy con
un aumento de la actividad de misiles
sirenas de tanques aéreos ya han sonado
repetidamente muchas ciudades ucranianas
durante este día no hubo nada bagayoko
krinsky estar por su parte naciones
unidas señaló que todavía se están
ultimando los detalles para el envío de
seguro de granos ucranianos desde su
puerto en el mar negro el primer barco
de cargamento podría zarpar el viernes